amici miei sono ritornati su il mio
cavallo di battaglia il canale è fatto
per questo il giappone è la terra che io
amo e questo lo sapete tutti in giappone
ho avuto modo di conoscere un sacco di
stranezze legate al mondo nipponico
iscrivetevi perché parlo veramente bene
che quando voi guardate le pubblicità
giapponesi non trovate pubblicità come
quelle italiane le trovate molto più
trash e oggi andiamo a fare la rwe
action desco allora c'è uno zio che sta
mangiando stava mangiando che cosa sta
succedendo allora io è raro che in un
secondo di video trovo già la copertina
perché non ho parole
[Musica]
tutto questo per vendere dei noodle al
manzo diamo avanti
oddio che carino
si può ma da centrato tra infetti con
bribon
ma come ma cosa qui cosa ho visto questa
roba da assaggiata una volta fa vomitare
però va bene la cosa doveva 21 subito
perché è una punta tutto sto casino per
una bibita o è solo un abilità ma perché
c'è super mario che gioca a golf e
spiega mi supermario giochi olimpici
sparatoria ha sparato si può armare i
giochi olimpici
[Musica]
cos'è che era ma non c'entra niente non
ero gioca una bibita va come non ho
capito niente di quello che sta
succedendo è uno sponsor per dei led che
hanno in mano delle barre led
non lo so stanno sponsorizzando voi così
che animano del recco è una bibita per
non sapere
l'unica a erano veramente i neon ragione
no fermi ho visto la vita perché c'é rue
che in una pubblicità giapponese io che
per chi non lo sapesse il ragazzone in
that not che gioca profumo braccio
questo chiudere mentre l asse anche se
non è vero nome della
uno shinigami dio della morte famiglia
perché ha messo per whatsapp questo è ai
controlli diciamo che il problema tanto
sarà la pubblicità di una bibita in
tutto questo deve aprire la valigia è
sta anche un po su dando quindi
attenzione sopra qualcosa incredibile la
bambina perplessa sono già pronta al
trash lo sapevo io lo sapevo
[Musica]
vero ma cosa c'entra ma perché ski aree
non eretici per smartphone e ci sono i
polli nella valigia bellissima ci hanno
fatto un canale youtube giusto pollo qua
non so se lo sapevate ma geniale
tensione ci siamo e ci siamo è quello
che aspettavo da una vita
ragazzi siamo qui un miliardo di pikachu
soffici che schermo rimane ridotto per
tacere non si è capito cos'era però per
favore
bellissimo stai cercando di
pubblicizzare yu gi oh
hai la mia attenzione amico io ho capito
solo union i progressi aiuti o per
telefono
2 links dall'altro oh mio dio l'uomo
ramen attenzione è il power ranger dei
ramen il rame nel range va bene ufo buy
co sto vedendo madonna bellissimo
effetti speciali co ceo di sun king
intera che poi c'è un arena ok frecce
avvelenate un gioco non so quanto questa
scena possa essere family friendly
ragazzi per il parlamento di nuovo
andiamo avanti ragazzi cosa è successo è
arrivato un messaggio occhio tipo league
of legends clash of legends
ma cosa ho visto tensione ragazzi c'è la
luna piena
mio dio è un licantropo come michael
jackson nel thriller wigan travaglio e
quindi rahaman giusto questa c'entra
rave ma perché c'è un ritardo cosa che
gli ha detto ok
conti gennaio contro le pagine tanti ma
che razza è quel cane per cortesia non
so me fancesi console panci ma che
stiamo vedendo se partire o no
[Musica]
giusto mi sono consumate tonalità soft
pensi che ho visto non ho capito niente
po po po di tutto tutto ma che a
supercazzola tar evoluzionista sex toys
times è dirlo subito
tutto ciò du ballet così basta
[Musica]
bruce willis cosa sta facendo solo su
quelli sponsorizzati
io non ne posso più
fatemi finire questo video vi prego
cos'è
perché c'è un uomo pane o la con le
banane questa spiegami come ci è finita
in questa posizione come possibile come
fate a finire in posti così sente il
cane che guarda le bolide occhio stanno
nuotando hai una casa e un e skype room
tipo
tutti mentis non ci credo ci sia poco da
roba qua basta
ti prego basta ora sui come sa e la
suite a ragazzi e la sua unica lo so i
vini che si applicavano una volta è
stata beccata una volta che il pinguino
la troika e la carta del lo spiego cosa
sperava che vede praticamente la suite a
questa che non si vede perché c'è il
green screen
attenzione però che ebbe e verde fate
finta che è verde quindi equa e verde
praticamente è la tessera va che figata
che non si vede attraverso bellissimo e
la tessera del della metro del giappone
proveniente durata quando va in metro
non metti i soldi il biglietto non serve
una sega fai questa che tu e appoggi su
cosa è passa ai tornelli infatti il
giappone su ste cose e avanti in una
maniera incredibile qua dietro ci sono
le istruzioni potete leggerle se volete
non so se vi interessa è però potete
leggerlo
supermario attenzione qualcosa stop ed è
tuo
ragazzi come si prende sto power up in
super mario non lo conoscevo la roma non
ci credo per socializzare una macchina
hanno fatto questa cosa
super mario bros la macchina bellissimo
lecito mario eccolo che cazzuto questo
mario meli contro la mercedes subito
ragazzi questa era le best commercial di
oggi i giapponesi bellissime
beh non so cosa dire sono esterrefatto
però complimenti veramente noiosa mese
pubblicità del genere guardare la tv lo
dico sempre lo ripeto bellissimo però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi se mi è
piaciuto che ci ha detto se mi piace
schiacciato il tasto iscriviti e la
campanella e tratti di fianco che è
molto importante così rimane da giovani
si video che escano e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video ora prossima
pubblicità che non si sa mai bella
ragazzi
[Musica]